have kind of spoke of life as suffering
uh do you think there's truth to that
that suffering is a is a fundamental
part of life
I think it is a fundamental part of life
I don't think that means that life is
suffering right if we say well life is
suffering then what am I doing that I'm
trying to erase from my mind like the
birth of my children right like things
that were filled with joy right like
life is not entirely suffering but life
brings a lot of suffering and for some
people it brings such disproportionate
suffering and the people don't survive
the suffering and I think when people
are conscientious and empathic that that
really bothers us right the suffering in
our own lives and the fact that others
at times could could it seem to be so
overwhelmed by suffering that they don't
even get a chance
to see good and I think that there's I
do think there's truth to that and
there's sadness and distress to that but
to say therefore life is suffering I
think is just completely untrue and you
know it ignores the fact that someone
even made a trombone right let alone
that there's a little bit out of sync
and someone's playing the trombone like
that's cool there's there's a you know
there's elements of the Absurd that you
said are neat and interesting and and if
we start accepting that we can't
understand or control everything then we
can accept and I think really love and
Foster the beauty in our lives
yeah I think uh the word suffering is
doing a little bit too much work because
I think it's probably referring to the
philosophical concept of that uh
yeah this is absurd the absurdity right
that stuff just happens randomly
um evil people succeed good people fail
right there's a seeming random Injustice
on occasion right and occasion there's
Justice in uh yeah all of it that feels
like um
and maybe because it often there's a lot
of loss and then there's a kind of
matching complementary aspect to any
good feeling that all comes crashing
down like every hello right from a
physics perspective ends in a goodbye
like uh
that's a really sad thing like I've I've
uh you know all the amazing people I get
to meet in my life all the amazing
experiences eventually they have to end
and that's part of what makes them
amazing
but why is that sad is it because we're
taught to think let it look at some
point you and I are going to say goodbye
today like I hope we're richer for it
and then we take that goodness off with
us like I I want to celebrate that
because it's it's all part of the
goodness I think we're taught to think
oh that's so bad and it equates to death
and misery and
it's I think it's often not that way I
think there is a sadness to it but I
also don't think that sadness isn't a
negative thing it's a it's a different
way to celebrate a beautiful thing so
there's a melancholic nature to it or
something passing of of it leaving is
that old Louis CK thing that I go back
to over and over uh from from a show
Louis where um
uh he was all heartbroken that he just
broke up you know with the um with
somebody he loved
and he told about that to an old man and
the old man said uh you're a fool that's
the best part I missed that part where
you sort of are lingering in that loss
you're feeling the pain of that loss
because that lasts the longer it's the
most intense it's the most reliable and
it's a kind of celebration of the love
you had like losing the love is still a
celebration of the love
um I think you don't want to over
romanticize that but there's some aspect
of Truth to that like that melancholic
feeling of remembering a beautiful time
that's no longer there
is is a kind of celebration of it and is
a kind of Joyful experience even though
it it's very easy to experience it as a
negative emotion I think it's just like
you said I mean it's up to our mind to
determine how that emotions really felt
but it's a tricky one because it's like
heartbreak to experience that is a
positive thing people can reminisce at
funerals right and and laugh because
every people can be very very sad and
perceive that this that this person is
has died and perceived the sadness of it
but in perceiving that and really living
in it then you can have people who want
to remember that person by like telling
a funny story why because each of those
people carries that with them so I I
think what you're saying is is
consistent with healthy function as
human beings because we're going to
encounter sadness and loss like what do
we do with that right and do we do
things that ultimately create some
redemption or even reparation inside of
us and like reparation is a big word in
Psychology right it's how we repair
damage and loss so if we lose someone
and we're sad can we by telling funny
stories about that person remind
ourselves that hey they're still inside
of us whether they're out there look at
me I don't know but I can call that
person to mind inside of us and then we
have something that's that's good and
beautiful that comes of that too